ja das heißt das dass incidents regime
des kanzleramts der bundesregierung
endlich ein ende hat es schon gesagt
armin laschet hat das gestern in der
kanzler- nacht bei bild live verkündet
und heute wird es schon beschlossen hier
sieht man mal hier kann wahlkampf auch
wirklich etwas gutes haben denn die
bundesregierung oder zumindest
kanzlerkandidat armin laschet und auch
gesundheitsminister jens sparen wollen
einen weiteren lockdown im herbst
verhindern und das tut man am besten
indem man diese unsinnige zahl diesen
incidents wert der seit anderthalb
jahren unser leben bestimmt endlich aus
dem infektionsschutzgesetz streicht weil
diese zahl von anfang an reine willkür
war man muss es so klar sagen der
inzidenz wert ist schwachsinn er sagt
nichts darüber aus wie es wirklich um
die pandemie lage in deutschland steht
philipp nun haben wir uns ja alle
langsam heran getastet in der tat ist
aber ja schon lange klar und wir reden
schon sehr lange darüber nicht nur wie
bei bild sondern insgesamt wir reden
schon sehr lange darüber dass der
inzidenz wert alleine nicht reichen
kontron hat es jetzt doch wieder so
lange gedauert bis heute ja also
vollkommen richtig so dass experten
fordern das schon seit monaten
ich möchte hier mal einige nennen wie
hendrik strikt wie klaus stöhr wie jonas
schmidt-chanasit andreas gassen die
ganzen kritischen corona experten sagen
seit monaten auf den incidents wert ist
einfach kein verlass er sagt nicht aus
wie viele menschen krank sind wie viele
menschen sterben er sagt nur aus wie
viele menschen positiv getestet werden
das heißt inzidenz wert ist vollkommen
willkürlich wir schauen jetzt mal ganz
kurz rein wie armin laschet sich dazu
gestern hier bei uns geäußert hat aber
wir haben gelernt die inzidenz alleine
ist nicht mehr aussagekräftig die steht
aber immer noch im
infektionsschutzgesetz da steht immer
noch die inzidenz 50 drin obwohl jeder
weiß 5 und ihre kanzlerin da so wollte
erleichtert 50 ist heute nicht mehr das
gleiche wie vor einem jahr weil so viele
menschen geimpft sind und deshalb finde
ich muss man das infektionsschutzgesetz
jetzt sehr bald ändern
trotzdem warnen alle weiterhin vor einer
vierten welle
cdu csu generalsekretär blume hat vorhin
auch getan also es wird natürlich immer
gepaart mit der vorsicht wir können ja
auch vorsichtig sein aber wie
wahrscheinlich ist dass die vierte welle
und tatsächlich hart treffen wird ja das
werden wir sehen aber die es auf jeden
fall nicht mehr abhängig von den reinen
infektionszahlen denn die risikogruppen
sind mittlerweile fast komplett durch
kämpft also die menschen die wirklich
erkranken an krone die auf die
intensivstation kommen und auch schwerer
verläufe haben und sterben die sind
jetzt hervorragend geschützt deswegen
ist es so wichtig dass diese incidents
zahl endlich rauskommt aus dem
infektionsschutzgesetz und das politisch
brisante ist ja dass armin laschet etwas
durchsetzt also die inzidenz zahl
abschafft obwohl dieser eine kanzlerin
die cdu politikerin angela merkel ja so
lange wie nur möglich an der inzidenz
zahl festhalten wollte es war ihr corona
kurs sie hat sich von anfang an an die
incidents zahl gekettet und jetzt nutzt
armin laschet den wahlkampf um die
endlich aus dem gesetz zu streichen hat
natürlich auch einen guten großen
beraterkreis der ihr dazu geraten hat
das war ja keine einsame entscheidung
der kanzlerin das stimmt die kanzlerin
hat sich tatsächlich mit sehr vielen
experten umgeben die eine niedrig
inzidenz strategie gefordert haben da
sind melanie brinkmann michael meyer
hermann aber auch natürlich der spd
gesundheitspolitiker karl lauterbach
aber eine niedrig ins ziel incident
strategie heißt wir versuchen mit allen
mitteln die infektionszahlen zu drücken
und das heißt dauer locker und das hat
endlich ein ende
[Musik]